[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations it's I cannot think of a
especially in comedy a director writer
that's that's had the kind of success
that you've had lately just your films
are just through the roof must be very
exciting for you yeah it's kind of
terrifying when things go well it makes
you think there's a bus around the
corner about to hit you yeah no I'm the
same way I have that same kind of
feeling always this way I avoid anything
ever going well for me
yeah like you know you think you're
gonna do well on Conan but then you have
to follow a duck that there's no
following that no performer Timberlake
won't tell that you are now so much to
talk about
you been very successful you work with
of course a Seth Rogen Jonah Hill and
you seems like you work with these guys
a lot you use them a lot why do you keep
using them and they're talented but but
why do you keep going back to them well
on one level I like goofy guys yes I
think they're underdogs
you know I think people like you know
people who are struggling in a movie
like I like you know the Bourne Identity
I like Matt Damon but I would like it
more if it started norm from Cheers
[Laughter]
really against him yeah watching him try
a scissor kick yeah we good but the main
reason I use them is just because
they're available you know they're just
home right now I you know if I want to
hire Lindsay Lohan I gotta call someone
who is Lindsay oh she's in rehab
Oh what about Tom Cruise or something oh
he's in Germany what about Seth he's
home right now playing guitar hero
[Laughter]
this is good and Jonah's right next time
waiting for his turn cleaning like the
screen of a bomb yeah they need cleaning
constantly seth rogen of course you
worked with freaks and geeks I did how
was he at the time he was 16 years old
when I met him and it was very weird for
me because I'm like the boss at the show
and and he's 16 I remember one night I I
said I should hang out with these kids I
never hang out with them you know see
what they're up to so I walked over to
Seth and all the actors I said what are
you guys doing tonight Seth goes well
whatever we were gonna do we ain't gonna
do it now but now you've been with him a
long time it feels like you've you
followed him you've taken him through
the this important part of his career ya
know I'm you know I'm very proud of and
we just actually was excited we heard
that President Clinton requested the the
video of knocked up to watch on a plane
to Europe is it true yeah like president
couldn't requested - he wanted a special
get him a special tape so he can watch
it on a plane - some probably important
conference yeah you seem to be sitting
with important people watching like a
baby come out of a vagina he relates to
every joke in the movie for some reason
yes it's reefer and sex and all of that
yeah so I'm excited you know you know
he's after he watches the movie he's
gonna say is it really a website called
mr. skin can I gonna be the next phone
call there's a lot of knocked-up a lot
of the film draws on some of your own
experiences and I I'm guessing hilarious
sequence with the OBGYN where the baby's
about to be born
and the doctor suddenly is unavailable
and I guess that came from your own life
story yeah did you know we go to the
doctor one day and we say we think we're
having the baby and he said no you're
not and we went home and then you know
she was clearly having the baby so we we
called the doctor and he was gone he was
at a Bar Mitzvah he jumped a plane the
second that we left the office right so
now we're driving to the hospital with
no doctor so we're kind of in a panic
and so we started calling the doctors
that we had met with that we didn't like
and had to have one of those people come
tonight people that that know that you
turned them down yes exactly so
disgruntled OBGYNs yeah and you know and
so there's one guy showed up and he just
clearly was was mad because anything we
would ask a question he would say you
want to be the doctor go home
you be the doctor you decide and the
worst part is these enormous hands in
giant hands you know you don't want like
a guy you know delivering the baby with
giant hands you want to got the gluteal
American girl baby doll hands
we know these babies now you've had so
much success but it's always I think
it's important to stress that things
have not always gone well yes they've
been struggling parts of your parts of
your career we struggled yeah there was
I guess you had a potential project with
the Rolling Stones at one point that
never really got off the ground what
happened there well a long time ago
after the Ben Stiller show was canceled
we were hired by the Rolling Stones to
write a movie for them a comedy as you
would expect them to do and it was
supposed to be you know Ben and another
guy it was supposed to be potentially
Brad Pitt following them you know on the
road and a little story line in between
the songs and the concert films so there
was just crazy like three-week time
period where Mick Jagger called my house
a lot which was really weird I mean I
recorded every single phone call with it
because I knew it would fall apart right
I just wanted to know that it happened
and then I would sample things he said
so anytime I made a mistake on my
computer I would hear Mick Jagger so I
hit the wrong button would be like I'm
tired that's funny
but that's good but you got something
out of it even though this project would
you ever get a meeting with the other
guys in the band yeah yeah it was very
exciting to go to Toronto when they were
rehearsing and pitched the movie to the
band which is terrifying like looking at
Keith Richards trying to make him laugh
right I mean this is the worst audience
on earth right and it'd been so
confident pitching the movie he's like I
want it to be edgy and and and rough
kind of like Gimme Shelter was and Keith
Richards goes yes but this time let's do
it without the murder being with the
devil and then Ron Wood kept raising his
hand going let's do it
let's do it and the key for inches you
get something annoyed with him he's like
yeah are you gonna direct Alfred
Hitchcock they're like an old married
couple keep quiet and each of the
biskits